your surgeon will perform an abdominal
aortic aneurysm repair
to prevent the rupture of a bulging area
of your aorta endovascular aneurysm
repair your surgeon will begin by making
a small incision in your groin over your
femoral artery then he or she will
insert a guide wire into the artery and
gently push it up toward the site of
your aneurysm
a catheter
tube will be passed over the guidewire
and pushed toward your aneurysm using
live x-ray pictures as a guide your
surgeon will pass an endovascular stent
graft a compressed fabric and metal tube
through the catheter to the aneurysm
then he or she will open the graft which
will be held in place with metallic
hooks and stents your surgeon may insert
additional graft components to extend
the graft into the blood vessels
supplying your legs once the graft is in
place your blood will flow through it
not into the surrounding aneurysm sac
which will remove the pressure from your
aneurysm finally your surgeon will
remove the catheters and close the
incisions in your groin the procedure
will generally take two to three hours